hey what up king sting oh he's australia
my name is nick i'm from nantucket
island
uh i love you guys i've been watching
y'all since the jump
it's kind of king interesting it kind of
relationship advice
so a little back story i was dating this
girl for a while
kind of an exhibitionist sent me a lot
of photos and videos
and kind of provocative stuff proven
fortunately kovid
got a hold of her and uh she's no longer
with us but she
was a straight up dime i mean
like something you can't even shake a
stick at so
king or sting it starting only fans with
your
hot dead girlfriend i love this guy
uh yeah i
need some cash so that's where where
it's at
i'll include a pick as long as brandon
doesn't uh start pushing rope over it
and other than that gang gang buzz buzz
let me know
i was just kidding about your hair yeah
thanks
i like this guy he included a pic he
didn't and i emailed him back
he said i have to subscribe oh did he
really yeah
priceless that's good businessman
businessman that's a businessman that's
mark cuban
that's amazing that's the next mark
cuban dude yeah that is definitely
mark nantucket for sure uh dude
so only let me ask you this when you did
watch porn
if you found out your favorite porn star
passed away
would you stop watching her movies well
i
always thought that they should have a
deceased section like an r.i.p section
um but yeah i think it's weird to watch
something maybe it's somebody that's
deceased if they're a lot but i don't
know maybe that's why they did it so
it'd still be out there i still listen
to michael jackson
yeah but you're not listening to them
having sex with the kids
you know i'm saying if that was the all
like if that's what you know
yeah they'll be different i feel like i
mean i'll why
i don't know yeah i'll still listen
to nirvana you will yeah will you that's
a good point yeah i will
that's a really good point brennan
somehow thanks man uh
here's the thing about his only fans
with his deceased girlfriend who got
coveted
i love it i think you have to honor the
family somehow though build up
i don't think the family's gonna dig it
but also the families ask for all the
money
and then also how many picks you have
dude how long is this gonna last
maybe three months but let's say you
have a lot maybe three months worth of
material yeah then what dude
he's got three months hurrah and then
he's gonna be getting his [ __ ] pale
ass on there
taking ass pics and stuff well then i
think you start faking you hire somebody
that looks like her
who is ill to do it
and and say oh this is towards the end
of her run
yeah and she's still sending them yeah
she's getting older lady
like that old saggy ass like look what
it did to her ass
what kova did to her yeah um oh you
think you still post
good pics yeah i think you want to honor
the quality that's one thing i don't
like about i don't have any only fan
subscriptions but
i i i think you want to honor the
quality of
putting out good stuff you know do you
have any uh
chin i don't nick you do no
my girlfriend christian nick can't do
any of that
i got i got a i got a buddy who has only
fans accountability
he's still allowed to be here today
nick has been put on notice several
times it's good
breaking bad habits it's good no it's
good it's good
good for you man yeah i got a buddy with
a bunch only fans account
what about chunk meat which you got fam
[Applause]
i mean i've subscribed to like one or
two
wait wait wait nobody's believing that
meatballs
like i always want to be like oh what
are they doing like i wanted to see what
they were posting because
i mean why not and the girls from your
heights is it good stuff
no i immediately regret spending the
money my boy who spent i mean he
probably has
15 to 20 only no man how dare you
he probably has 50 or 20 only fan
accounts that he looks at he shows me
the videos
dude i mean they are getting after are
they
dude i mean because they got to get that
money man it's like god damn girl
porn when does it end you know
i also don't like how when you sign up
for only fans they can see
like your name like if you don't if
you're not smart enough to like put like
a fake name
they can when you subscribe to someone's
account they can see who you are
we'll be smart enough yeah yeah okay
you're talking about that happened to
you
no no no yeah yeah like when i first
signed i put a fake name when i first
signed up i thought i was like why
would people not do this true yeah like
i don't like that
name like i don't like how you can see
their your information if it was
completely anonymous
i'd be on the only offense what name did
you put meatball
uh i think i pull like john white or
something like that i put something
random
hold on i'm from like western talking
about somebody that came over on the
mayflower dude
john white yeah come on man you get
names from the civil war
that's the best we get john white
meanwhile there's 200 john white's
following the lady
john white ball yeah now are some of
them more expensive than others
cats in the world there are some girls
who are busted that like will make their
account like 30 to like 50 dollars and
then like you click on it
and we'll say one picture one video like
people
subscribe to that but they'll charge 50
bucks a month
like up to 50 bucks a month some people
and they'll post like maybe one thing
yeah you seem pretty into it yeah you
see what happens in my details
it's called the library it's not hard to
like once you go on at once like oh
really
to figure out like oh look i'll see like
the only fan's ads like i'll click on it
just to see
we know a lot about it bubba yeah you
know a lot about it meatball yeah
i like to go on and see what they like
see how much they're charging so it's
not judging
dude hey you're not in the court of law
here man yeah
his main concern is the business
practices yeah
maybe i can help them out maybe i can
get them more money you know not a bad
idea
sure man yeah yeah jesus christ
that shake is great though man great
shakespeare thanks bro i appreciate that
[Music]
is